stéphanie grammond michel sauget à la
question gay bonsoir
bons soins elle a été députée du bloc
qu'elle a été mairesse de longueuil elle
a été juteuse avec paul de l'autre côté
sera t elle la prochaine député de
sherbrooke pour la cac la cac qui
appartient la claque la partie
sherbrooke qui appartient à québec
solidaire
actuellement
madame l'abri c'est intéressant s'est
faite autour de tables stéphanie
grammond retour donc possiblement
politique active comme député de carbine
saint-hilaire oui ben c'est un secret de
polichinelle depuis que l'équité la
joute là à la fin d'année dernière pour
le monde s'imaginait bien qu'elle
reviendra en politique on pensait que ce
serait la circonscription de marie
victorin et qui a été un peu naturel
mais finalement j'ai dit non on sort des
sentiers battus sherbrooke oui c'est
vrai candidat de prestige d'une
candidate longue carrière politique
mais en même temps à sherbrooke elle
n'est pas nécessairement si connus des
électeurs il faudra voir si c'est pas
elle qu'on voyait les gens il est
mélangé les pinceaux la wii c'est pas
elle mais continue et je m'excuse
stéphanie c'est juste que je ne sais pas
la maison mais c'est pas elle non non ce
n'est pas elle envoie mettre la bonne à
l'elysée excusez moi tout est clair
maintenant alors
elle a une longue expérience politique
peut-être moins connus à sherbrooke et
mais ça manque que la caf veut vraiment
offrir une opposition là québec
solidaire qui qui elle allait le conte
et la circonscription avec les kristine
labrie mais ces circonscriptions que
changer dans l'histoire mais tu aimais
de reprise de parti politique ça a été
monsieur charest l'ancien premier
ministre a été battu dans cette
circonscription la parole péquiste en
fait ça ça a changé plusieurs fois de au
cours de la dernière décennie donc ça va
être ça va vraiment intéressant de
surveiller ce que ça donnera cette
fois-ci michel qu'est ce que ça vous dit
la réaction que j'ai eu quand j'ai vu
c'est une affaire officiel je suis à
thiais chez le look vraiment gagner plus
que sans compter
s'il ne laisse aucun compte et au hasard
et c'est une excellente candidate faut
pas en douter c'est quelqu'un qui a une
habitude des débats qui chambre des
communes en même temps vous avez parlé
de notre ami paul l'autre côté de la rue
là il ya des tonnes et des tonnes le
registre main de dame sainte claire
contre troisième y est contre le
gouvernement du québec qui prend les
municipalités pour
pousser ses valets concours contre
l'étalement urbain contre eux quelque
chose comme ça l'a
utilisé contre
wayne john atta qui est ici avec nous
régulièrement
à tweeté un extrait de la joute avec
pale où elle était fait remarquer que le
troisième vient lui était plutôt pour à
l'époque donc c'est bizarre mais alex a
ça fait partie de comment dire
l'évolution qu'ont les candidats on peut
dire bon ben je vois les choses d'un
autre angle on m'a expliqué que c'était
au
niveau de charlie de richmond peu plus
tard ce printemps dans marie-victorin
qui avait critiqué le gouvernement parce
qu'il ne reconnaissait pas le racisme
système est cassé quand même présenté
pour françois legault il a gagné dans ma
des victorino cunha ces petites
contorsions là qu'on fait souvent
lorsqu'on est en politique depuis si
longtemps probablement caroline
st-hilaire aurait davantage porter les
couleurs du parti québécois c'est quand
même une ancienne députée du bloc
caroline st-hilaire affiché
souverainiste a ouvertement qu'ils
décident finalement d'y aller pour la
cac ça montre aussi les difficultés que
rencontrent parti québécois ce genre de
candidature leur aurait dû lui
appartenir à une certaine époque ce
n'est plus le cas pour cherbourg une
course intéressante parce que c'était
fini a raison je tends conduite unis
placent souvent d'un parti à un autre
beaucoup d'encre a jusqu au t2 caroline
st-hilaire elle vit le bol mais c'est
pas quelqu'un qui a une longue feuille
de route dans sherbrooke et kristine
labrie de québec solidaire et pas battu
un québec solidaire la tendance à 2 à
s'incruster dans les circonscriptions où
lyon des députés sont réélus la plupart
du temps et donc
une belle bataille mais c'est pas parce
que tu étais rollins et il est quelqu'un
de connu telle voie nécessairement
l'emporter je pense que les gens de
sherbrooke pourront faire leur choix sur
différents critères que la notoriété ça
va être intéressant comme comme bataille
les le quément bus souci il ya des
jeunes une université donc je vote
davantage québec solidaire mais sa
notoriété quand même
fait qu'elle part en créant une vraie
bataille dans sherbrooke qu'on va suivre
effectivement très bien alors voilà même
saint-hilaire aux prochaines élections
je pense que elle va présider d'ailleurs
quand on a su qu'elle présidait le
congrès de la caq donc celle ci c'était
une bonne indication
ou une politique qui n'a pas de vocation
qui sont permanents c'est donc cette
fois la première a changé de parti que
ce ne sera pas la dernière mais elle est
là et on va devoir s'expliquer alors
devant la force ou la faiblesse de ces
associations des électeurs de sherbrooke
la braderie au sérieux
à
cet exercice là au premier j'ai changé
d'idée aussi pourquoi très bien mesures
sanitaires des voyageurs
et donc délai que sa cause dans les
grands aéroports du pays
la chef de l'opposition officielle a
attaqué le gouvernement aujourd'hui là
dessus je vous présente pas d'extrait
l'homme est assez simple pour vous s'il
vous plaît faire le ménage dans les
mesures parce que l'oeil à un goulot
d'étranglement il ya des gens qui
régulièrement j'allais me dire ce pas
dramatique sur l'échelle des malheurs
mais quand même d'attendre une heure et
demie deux heures dans un appareil
plutôt que de descendre parce qu'on
n'est pas prêt à les recevoir je
commence avec vous alec là dessus est ce
que le gouvernement fédéral doit faire
le ménage au plus vite des mesures
sanitaires qui touche les voyageurs aux
frontières et aux aéroports notamment
il ya plusieurs facteurs qui expliquent
les délais actuels dans les grands
aéroports canadiens les mesures
sanitaires sont une arrive kahn le fait
qu' on interroge les passagers aussi sur
leurs symptômes mais ce qu'ils sont en
santé ou non qu'on fasse des tests
aléatoires des terminaux qui ne sont pas
adaptés pour faire ces tests là donc
faut réduire l'espace pour être capable
de tester les gens donc oui certainement
que ça ajoute des délais mais aussi la
la pénurie de main d'oeuvre manque de
gardiens de il manque de deux
responsables de sécurité il manque
également de douaniers on allait
probablement pas embaucher suffisamment
dans la dernière année et demie parce
qu'on n'avait pas assez de monde à
l'aéroport donc on voulait pas payer des
gens à ne rien faire mais là ça a pris
du retard un ex en partie à la retraite
on n'a pas comblé les postes dont qu'il
soit aussi ce qui est inquiétant là
dedans c'est qu'on n'est même pas dans
la saison touristique forte ben si ça
aussi on a des deux trois heures
d'attentes à toronto parfois une heure
deux heures sur le tarmac à revenant de
voyage qu'on peut même pas entraîner
dans l'aéroport parce qu'il est plein
imaginez ce que ça va être au mois de
juillet et au moins doux quand on va
recevoir non seulement les canadiens qui
reviennent des touristes étrangers il
faut trouver une solution je suis pas un
spécialiste de la logistique
aéroportuaire mais faut que le
gouvernement ça soit avec les grandes
infos par là qu'on règle les problèmes
parce que honnêtement ça va être une
catastrophe dans quelques semaines
michel
deux choses je suis d'abord je voudrais
dire que je ne suis pas de techno plus
haut que je me croyais assez bien
et j'ai utilisé deux fois arrive cannes
depuis depuis quelques mois qu'un jour
venu au canada les deux fois ça n'a pas
marché et obligé de retourner en arrière
de l'année c'est un aria avec un drap et
s'il vérifie on vous êtes obligé de
donner une adresse pour où vous allez
passer la quarantaine si jamais vous a
déclaré que m château de windsor cerveau
marché immo regarde alors à quoi ça rime
je ne sais pas mais c'est politique
d'autre part quand vous avez des tas de
gens qui apparaît en ligne que ce soit à
dorval ou à pearson à toronto ou
ailleurs ça c'est un bête pour que le
chrono virus se déplacent
l'aéroport lui-même peu pour répondre à
la demande c'était pire ça que
d'abandonner chi minh et quelques
mesures sanitaires qui reste
je mets beaucoup compris pourquoi on
insiste état et on est pas mal et bien
oui on est les derniers mais comme si
stéphanie on avait été à cause du tout
au tout début traumatisé plus qu'on
voulait pas aller trop vite mais là on
est comme le bon on a quand même oublié
de fermer la lumière ou de l'allumer
plus tôt cette année
mais sur une balance
avec la corrida mais bon enfin les la
question qu'on doit se poser c'est
est-ce que c est ce que ces règles leurs
sanitaires sont encore utiles et je
pense que le masque dans les transports
c'est faisable c'est possible de
conserver ainsi souhaitable
d'ailleurs on voit aux états unis
aujourd'hui que les autorités sanitaires
disent qu' il faudrait que les peut-être
le tien les américaines dans les régions
plus
poussée plus difficile recommence à
porter le masque à l'intérieur parce
qu'il ya une augmentation des
hospitalisations et bonjour le match je
pense que exact donc je pense que le
masque est important en phase avancée on
doit garder le passeport vaccinale c'est
une autre histoire
aqua 500 exactement faudra que le
gouvernement fédéral nous lui explique
parce que si l'idée c'est de ces de se
servir de ça comme outil pour convaincre
les gens de se faire vacciner
je pense qu'à ce point ainsi ceux qui
sont pas fait vacciner c'est parce
qu'ils voient les convaincre par
ailleurs ces idées se dit ben on veut
pas que la coville se répandent d'accord
mais on exige plus passent par vaccinale
dans l'est dans les endroits comme le
centre bell où il ya un paquet mandat
lorsque ces logiques j'en suis pas
convaincu donc on a besoin de davantage
l'explication je crois à ce point-ci
pour savoir à quoi à quoi tout cela est
utile exactement très bien sécurité des
élus fédéraux on va voir ensemble la
scène qu'on a beaucoup vu la semaine
dernière où jack meeting ce fait un
risque se fait pousser ce fait dire
salut trade vendus et c est
la question que ça pose
c'est que contrairement à québec
alec les élus et les chefs fédéraux ne
sont pas suivies le premier ministre
bien sûr mais les autres ne sont pas
suivies n'ont pas de gardes du corps
armés avec eux parce qu'on doit changer
ça selon vous compte tenu qu'on n'est
pas en train de dire qu'elle ne pluie de
menaces toujours sérieux mais a quand
même plus de manas qui en avait et on ya
25 ans alec
voilà la réponse courte si oui on a un
peu d' angélisme canadiens ici là en
pensant que nos élus ne seront jamais
apostrophé sur la rue qui subissent
aucune menace c'est pas vrai il y en a
eu dans le passé pourtant eux-mêmes des
menace très directe autant l'assemblée
nationale qui avait à la chambre des
communes des des gens qui sont rentrés
armés dans ces enceintes la caisse
qu'ils empêcher d'attaquer un élu sur la
rue un ministre hector on est au pays du
g7 du g20 nous ministres mélanie joly
mais les enfers étrange à ce problème
hélas aucun garde du corps à la personne
avec elle qu'il a qui la protège la
surveille ça fait des années que les
élus en coulisse lorsqu'on leur parle
dénonce cette situation là mais on
commet un peu peur d'aller publiquement
de discuter on aimerait ça aide un peu
mieux protéger les des situations où on
n'est pas à l'aise comme si ton espèce
de tabous d'angélisme canadiens comme je
voulais pas être comme aux états unis où
lee les représentants sont mieux
protégés je pense qu'on est dans une
société qui s'est jusqu'à un certain
point radicaliser et à droite à gauche
plus polarisé que jamais la pandémie a
accéléré sa et nos élus sur lui qu'ils
fassent leur travail sereinement devrait
être mieux encadré ça a été le cas
pendant qu'on voit dit camionneurs on
allait des agents de la grc qui ont
accompagné françois blanchet par exemple
de son appartement gatineau jusqu'à la
chambre des communes même chose pour
jacques meeting pourquoi est ce que
c'est une mesure exceptionnelle tant
mieux si si pendant que dix choses
exceptionnelles qui produisons les
protège mieux mais je pense qu'on
devrait réviser sa et avoir une
conscience que ses élus le sont
peut-être un petit peu plus
approche trophy qu'il l'était et les
réseaux sociaux moment donné ça déborde
dans la réalité est qu'on dormait voirie
nous dans les roches les roches lancé
monsieur trudeau le faut dire qu'en
campagne ils le sont tous les chefs
protégés l'yonne ils ont la même
protection à peu près que le pm en
campagne michel
on n'a peut-être pas besoin d'avoir des
gardes du corps armés tout le temps avec
chaque ministre député mais là gers et
des autres corps de police font
régulièrement des évaluations des du
danger des évaluations de situation et
il ya des situations comme maintenant
mon collègue de gas gas un véhicule ils
ne m'ont pas oublié on le somme ça
d'ailleurs dans les rues des fois dans
le métro vous voyez que des
comportements
alors la police c'est ça la jirs ccsa et
elle peut dire à certaines périodes
cette période serait probablement une
bonne période pour sa désormais la façon
pas permanente mais de façon temporaire
ou fournir de la protection surtout pour
des chefs de parti des minispaces que
c'est pourquoi
pas non plus les coupes et déjà moi je
vais j'ai vécu les états unis puis je
peux vous dire que même si pelosi a
accordé sa reborn m c'était moi non plus
[Rires]
on voudrait pas complètement hockey au
québec les chauffeurs sont à remiser les
gars de l'unss qcd membres je poursuis
son terme et je vois succès permet peut
être c'est vraiment bien ce qu ces
chauffeurs je pense que celui de mise la
justice et celui du premier ministre et
à ma connaissance par
stéphanie mais moi je pense que ça
serait même attendre qu'il ya quelqu'un
qui est un élu qui soit assassiné comme
on l'a vu au royaume uni l année
dernière je pense que on devrait fournir
plus de protection de manière
systématique aux os et aux ministres
fédéraux et celle qu au québec c'est un
peu étrange comme l'année dernière de
voir le ministre reçoit philippe
champagne qui arrivent au québec il s'en
rend un événement il ya deux ministres
du provincial qui sont leurs et puis
c'est les gardes du corps du provincial
qui sont obligés de dire monsieur
champagne écoute voici le meilleur accès
pour entrer parce qu'il ya des
manifestants qui s'est compliqué c'est
quand c'est ce qu'ont normal il me
semble que ces gens là vivent déjà un
grand stress oui il ya plus
d'agressivité et non ce n'est pas que
sur les médias sociaux attendons pas que
quelqu'un
me soit vraiment victime de quelque
chose de regrettable
comme disait alec et comme on a peur
d'aller là on a peur des symboles de ce
que ça va envoyer comme la rénovation du
24 sussex on va prendre une retraite
l'astroport régler ça va être très bien
rinne
vote de confiance juste j'estime qu'à
nice il appelle quant à lui mais là
c'est dans une heure et demie deux
heures qu'on aura les résultats
tour de taille quand on sait que vu ses
fanions septembre vous attendez à quoi
je vous montre une prévision mais c'est
quand même il est un peu dans un coin
puis pour se sortir du coin ya besoin
d'un bon d'un bon score
oui c'est certain son parti c'est le
parti conservateur unis mais c'est
peut-être plus tôt le parti conservateur
d une île depuis un certain temps et
puis on le voit le la contestation et
des nouveaux partis qui ce qui émerge
donc le wildrose et puis le buffalo
alors on voit que y est très contestée
ça va prendre un vote solide en sa
faveur même si même s'il était lui même
s'il pense peut-être qu'ils vont vouloir
aller quand même en est en élection pour
avoir un signal encore plus puissant
mais sauf que là c'est pas
nécessairement gagné non plus parce
qu'elle a la chef du npd elle est en
profitent de cette de cette drogue donc
c'est vraiment et c'est vraiment à voir
qui va être déterminant peut-être qu'on
aura des élections en alberta plutôt que
plus tard ben oui michel un petit mot et
elle est quand conclusion
l'exercice bomag années monsieur kenny
l'exercice lui même chef politique
beaucoup plus faible aujourd'hui au
départ et qu'il gagne ou qu'il perde
c'est quelqu'un qui va arriver au moment
des élections de s'y perdre non mais ce
même s'ils gagnent et marigot au moins
des extraits et j'y allais qu
il a mis la barre très basse des cinq
années il a discuté sujet plus de 50%
des voix je me restait certes c'est
comme cela que ça se passait
généralement si on n'est pas avec un
très bon pourcentage de plus de trois
quarts des voiles un chef déjà été
fragilisés puis il ya des gens à l'inter
de son parti qui veulent sa tête des
gens très connus le brain gym dansée
chef du wildrose d'agneau smit l'autre
en chef 06 veut se présenter aux
élections qui était une animatrice de
radio très connu à calgary maintenant
bien des genres qui qui vont pas se
contenter de 52% à 53 pour ça on le
laisse en place ça va lui prendre un
très bon résultat et la question c'est
qu'est-ce qui fait si leurs 55 60 61%
qui peut rester ce qui veut se maintenir
ce qui les couteaux vont sortir ça va
être intéressant de voir le résultat on
aura le résultat plus tard en soirée
stéphanie michel c'est alec merci
beaucoup bonne soirée au revoir à
bientôt au revoir
[Musique]